this is a shirley card
and if you developed color film between
the 1940s and the 1990s
the accuracy of the colors in your
photos were pretty much
based on this skin tone shirley was
probably the name
of the first person who was pictured on
the cards
and surely became the subsequent name of
all the women pictured on the card
that's lorna roth a professor and
researcher at concordia university in
montreal
usually they were white women who wore
very colorful dresses
color film works like this there are
layers of chemicals stacked on each
other
that are sensitive to different colors
of lights and there are a series of
different types of chemical solutions
that are used to develop them once
exposed to that light
a combination of all of these chemicals
creates a film's color balance
and for many decades chemicals that
would bring out various reddish
yellow and brown tones were largely left
out
the consumer market that was designated
in the design of film chemistry
was that of the lighter skinned market
so when it came to defining what an
idealized international skin tone
would be it turned out to be a lighter
skin tone than a darker skin tone
if you're shooting people with lighter
skins it looks good
if you're shooting people with darker
skins it doesn't look so good
if you're shooting mixed race in the
same screen
then we see the real problems
it wasn't until the 1970s where things
started to change and
it came from a very unlikely source
companies that were advertising
different kinds of wood furniture
were complaining that kodak film did not
render the difference between
dark grained wood and light grained wood
the other companies that kodak responded
to were chocolate makers
because the film couldn't render the
difference between dark chocolate
and milk chocolate as the film and
television industries became more
diverse
color balance issues at the professional
level became even more apparent
and in the 1990s a team of designers at
phillips and breda holland
tackled the issue head-on by developing
a camera system that used two different
computer chips
to balance lighter and darker skin tones
individually
first people to buy these cameras for
television they were called the ldk
series where oprah winfrey and black
entertainment television
like people who were very aware of these
issues
it was around this time that the white
shirley card was joined by the black
shirley card and the latino shirley card
in the multi-racial shirley card
and kodak's goldmax marketing campaign
emphasized their film's
improved dynamic range one of the things
that they said about gold max
is that gold max is a fine film
that can photograph a dark horse
in low light if you were his parents
would you trust this moment to anything
other than kodak gold film
no other film in the world gives you
truer color than kodak gold
today color film and digital camera
sensors have a much broader dynamic
range
but the default towards lighter skin and
technology
still lingers one of the big mistakes
emerged
in 2009 i'm sure you heard about it
my co-worker wanda and i are sitting in
front of an hp
media smart computer it's supposed to
follow me as i move
i'm black i think my blackness is
interfering with the computer's ability
to
to follow me so she moved this way and
the camera
followed her and then he'd get into the
screen and it would be
completely stable no face recognition
anymore buddy
my two separate but equal light meters
allow me to capture the pastiest whites
and the darkiest stars you deserve to
have those memories captured by a true
professional
not ruined by some hack who can't
accommodate different skin tone
the fact is there is still a cultural
bias towards lighter skin certainly in
how we use
technology and sometimes within the
technology itself
technology should be the ultimate
equalizer
it should serve everyone's needs without
an inherent bias
if a child is born into a society where
all of the range of skin tones is the
obvious norm
then they can no longer assume that
whiteness is default
[Music]
you